I'm gonna play for you today one of the
most outrageous and dangerous comments
I've ever heard from any elected
official ever and certainly that I have
covered on this program radical
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green said that if she had organized the
Insurrection coup Trump riots on January
6 2021 she would have been armed and
they would have won now what on Earth
does it mean that they would have won
well I think we have some pretty good
ideas of exactly what they mean we're
going to get to that Newsweek reporting
Marjorie Taylor green says Maga would
have won on January 6th if she organized
it what the hell is she talking about
Green was among the high-profile guests
to attend and speak at an event hosted
by the New York young Republican Club
that's a group that's got upper
management written all over it huh that
was in New York City on Sunday evening
Don Jr was there Rudy Giuliani was there
uh conspiracy theorist Jack zabiac was
there and the topic of the capital Riot
came up and here is Marjorie Taylor
green with again let's see if we can ex
understand exactly what she means saying
if she had run the riots they would have
won the riots interesting winning and
losing as the framing
which I thought was hilarious because I
couldn't even find the bathroom and the
capital
true story
then January 6th happens and next thing
you know I organize the whole thing
along with Steve Bannon here
and I want to tell yourself that if
Steve Bannon and I had organized that we
would have won
[Applause]
wow
not to mention it would have been armed
whoa
so it would have been a successful
more heavily armed insurrection
if Marge had been running the thing hmm
Second Amendment supporters went in the
capital without guns and they think they
think we organized that I don't think so
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I mean remember many of them flew
to DC so how exactly are they going to
bring their guns oh well you know you
could check it it's the the fact that
there weren't more guns because remember
there were guns doesn't really tell us
anything about it at all and there's no
both sides to it I mean this this is
this is fascism
wannabe important to mention we have to
stop treating the Republican party like
it's a normal political party I'm not
gonna do the Retro retrospective
Rehabilitation of the Republican party
I'm not going to do that
but I will recognize that there was a
time when the disagreements and the
differences with the Republican Party
we're more sane in nature I guess is
what I would say when it was really
about how involved should government be
in helping people to what degree should
the rich be taxed what should the top
tax rates be
there was a time where that was most of
it there was still the crazy stuff there
was I'm not going to pretend that there
was there was there was some of the
crazy stuff it's all crazy stuff now
it's all wannabe authoritarian fascist
dictatorships at this point in time do
whatever we need to do suppress speech
control the media use use prison or the
threat of prison to try to achieve
politicals it's there's no both sides at
this point in time Democrats are trying
to figure out how can we get everybody
health care Republicans are trying to
figure out how can we use guns to get
into office after losing an election
think about that contrast now
I wish you would elaborate on what
winning meant she says we would have won
the Insurrection if I had been in charge
I is she saying we would have
successfully overthrown the government
ending democracy as we know it in the
country by installing a dictatorial
leader who lost his election is that the
win that she's talking about I think it
has to be I don't know what else it
could be
we have to deal with this political
party
not as a normal political party but
rather
as a group of people who want to destroy
the American system of government who
don't care about the Constitution Trump
just said last week you can terminate
the parts of the Constitution that you
want when you believe you have been
wronged as he believes he was wronged in
2020. we have to treat them for what
they are now there's one other I guess
alternative for what it would mean to
have won which is maybe they would have
gotten a few senators and members of the
House killed right it wouldn't have just
been a demand to hang Pence maybe they
would have done it
and then he could have declared martial
law
and then he could have suspended the
election process and somehow convinced
people he should be president for an
additional four years I don't know maybe
maybe that's what a win would have
looked like but that's Marjorie Taylor
green she should obviously not be a
member of the House
uh Lauren bober won but barely Madison
cawthorne lost in her very red District
Marjorie Taylor green easily won the
real test now is going to be what
happens to these magas in 2024 we'll be
following it parents in the audience if
you're like me you're looking for fun
new things to do with your kids
meaningful enriching but fun enough to
keep them engaged every month our
sponsor Mel science sends you a box with
science experiments that combine
Hands-on Physical components with
virtual and augmented reality learning
science doesn't need to be boring it
doesn't need to be difficult many kids
are Hands-On Learners who absorb the
most through activities like these it's
perfect for homeschooling ages 5 through
High School five different subscriptions
to choose from chemistry physics stem
math or medicine Mel science sent me the
chemistry of monsters box where you grow
a black monster from sugar and make a
huge foam eruption in a flask but you're
actually learning about carbon dioxide
and unstable carbonic acid we had a ton
of fun with it the VR components are
awesome too it is really clear how this
helps kids tune into what they are
learning and my audience gets 50 off
your first month go to melscience.com
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below